ELLS DOES THAT CONVERSATION ON
TUCKER CARLSON TODAY AND WILL BE
ON FOX NATION TOMORROW MORNING
>> THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
COALITION IS EXPLODING AT THE
MOMENT.
JOE BIDEN'S SUPPORT AMONG
HISPANICS IS THE LOWEST AMONG
ANY ETHNIC GROUP IN THE UNITED
STATES.
WHO SAW THAT COMING?
AND THE EFFECTS OF IT ARE
DEMONSTRABLE.
SO JUST THE OTHER DAY, A SPECIAL
ELECTION TOOK PLACE IN THE RIO
GRANDE VALLEY IN TEXAS.
MAYRA FLORES, A REPUBLICAN,
FLIPPED A CONGRESSIONAL SEAT
THAT DEMOCRATS HAVE HELD FOR
OVER A CENTURY.
REALLY AN AMAZING STORY.
SHE JOINS US FOR HER FIRST
INTERVIEW SINCE BEING SWORN IN
AS A MEMBER OF CONGRESS.
CONGRESSMAN FLORES I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> Tucker: CONGRATULATIONS ON
YOUR WIN.
WHAT DOES IT MEAN?
HOW DID YOU DO THIS?
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN UNIMAGINABLE
TEN YEARS AGO.
>> HONESTLY I FOCUSED ON THE
ISSUES THAT REALLY MATTERED TO
MY DISTRICT.
WE'RE ALL ABOUT FAITH, FAMILY
AND HARD WORK.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHO WE ARE.
>> Tucker: AND SO -- YEAH, BUT,
I MEAN, IT WAS AN OVERWHELMINGLY
DEMOCRATIC DISTRICT.
>> YEAH, BUT, YOU KNOW, WE
DIDN'T HAVE THE FUNDING BEFORE.
WE DIDN'T HAVE THE FUNDING
BEFORE TO GET THE MESSAGE ACROSS
OUR DISTRICT.
AND NOW WE DO HAVE THE FUNDING
AND THE SUPPORT FROM THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
BUT PRIOR TO 2020, WE DID NOT
HAVE THAT SUPPORT.
WE WERE ALL ALONE.
YOU KNOW, THE DEMOCRAT PARTY
TOOK US FOR GRANTED, AND WE ALSO
DID NOT HAVE THE SUPPORT FROM
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
AND THAT'S, YOU KNOW, THAT'S A
FACT.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
NOBODY THOUGHT IT WAS POSSIBLE.
>> NO, NO ONE THOUGHT THAT WAS
POSSIBLE.
>> Tucker: IN WASHINGTON.
SO FAITH, FAMILY, HARD WORK.
>> YES, THAT'S WHO WE ARE.
THAT'S WHO WE'VE ALWAYS BEEN.
YOU KNOW, PEOPLE WILL TELL ME,
MAYRA, WHY ARE YOU REPUBLICAN?
WEREN'T YOU BORN IN MEXICO?
WELL, BECAUSE I WAS BORN IN
MEXICO IS I'M A REPUBLICAN
BECAUSE I WAS RAISED WITH STRONG
CONSERVATIVE VALUES AND I'M NOT
WILLING TO PUT THEM ASIDE TO A
POLITICAL PARTY.
I'M NOT LOYAL TO A PARTY.
I'M LOYAL TO GOD, MY FAMILY AND
MY COMMUNITY AND I TELL THE
PEOPLE IN SOUTH TEXAS WHO ARE
YOU LOYAL TO?
ARE YOU LOYAL TO GOD OR THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY.
AND THEY TELL ME NO I'M LOYAL TO
GOD.
OKAY STOP BEING LOYAL TO A PARTY
WHO'S DONE NOTHING FOR US FOR
OVER A HUNDRED YEARS.
>> Tucker: I DON'T THINK YOU'RE
ALLOWED TO SAY I'M LOYAL TO GOD
NOW THAT YOU'RE IN WASHINGTON
ARE YOU GOING TO KEEP SAYING
THAT?
>> ABSOLUTELY MY LOYALTY IS TO
GOD AND MY FAMILY, YES,
ABSOLUTELY.
GOD FIRST ALL THE WAY.
THAT'S WHY I WON, BECAUSE OF
HIM.
BECAUSE I LIVE IN PRAYER EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
>> Tucker: I JUST LOVE THIS.
I LOVE IT.
GOOD LUCK IN WASHINGTON.
I HOPE YOU ENJOY IT.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> Tucker: THEY'RE GOING TO MAKE
YOU TRY AND STOP SAYING THAT BUT
I HOP